the world is considerably less free than
it was in January 2020 right before the
covid-19 pandemic that was the theme of
a recent conversation that reason had
with Ian Vasquez who's one of the
co-authors of the annual human Freedom
index produced by the Cato and Frazier
institutes by Freedom we mean the
absence of coercive constraint the idea
that you can lead your life as you
choose as long as you respect the equal
rights of others and that's what we're
measuring in 2020 what we see is that
just the freedom falls off of a cliff
and America once among the leaders on
the freedom index has taken a
particularly bad slide in the rankings
it now sits as the 23rd freest country
in the world governments tend to claim
vast new powers over our lives in times
of war or crisis and then rarely give
them all back to unleash the full power
of the federal government did this
effort today I am officially declaring a
national emergency
two very big words
Vasquez points out that the recent
decline in Freedom goes back to the
collapse of the financial industry 15
years ago and before that the attack on
the Twin Towers and ensuing war on
terror the Year 2007 which is really the
the global high point of of human
Freedom that coincides with the
financial Global financial crisis which
came the next year and we see a steady
decline of human Freedom up through
2019. Vasquez says this is largely
because of a steady growth in the size
of government and erosion of the rule of
law do people think that the rules of
the game are fair or are being imposed
in an arbitrary way and it really
started with the beginning of the Bush
Administration and we think that that's
due to a lot of things the war on terror
the War on Drugs the weakening of
private property rights in the United
States with the kilo decision over a
decade ago I think that the financial
crisis has made things worse because
there was a rise of crony capitalism or
at least what people perceived as crony
capitalism or Industries and and in fact
particular companies close to power uh
got Privileges and when you have the
rules of the game not uh not viewed as
as Fair that's a real threat to other
freedoms as reason has covered
extensively the pandemic emboldened
Public Health officials and politicians
to do things that had no bearing on
safety such as closed beaches and
playgrounds and restrict our movements
they made it harder for landlords to
collect rent they gave out billions of
taxpayer money without any strings
attached and they arbitrarily shut down
entire Industries without any rational
justification on November 22nd Los
Angeles became the only County in
America to ban outdoor dining this
winter for a minimum of three weeks I
personally feel like we're being
punished LA Public Health director
Barbara Farrer held an online press
conference on November 23rd to discuss
the order given that you haven't
identified an actual source of an
outbreak being an outdoor dining how do
you rationalize the closure and how do
you expect to measure whether it
actually is accomplishing what you're
hoping to accomplish we know that places
where people are gathering without
wearing their face coverings are places
where transmission is easiest and most
likely
um but we will be you know as always
we'll watch our data what the perception
is of the rules of the game matters to
be able to uphold the system of justice
and other freedoms so what we've seen is
a deterioration during this time where I
think you can make the case that there
were a lot of arbitrary decisions being
made the good news for America is that
checks and balances do still exist
federal judges smacked down several
Governors Who overreached and the
Supreme Court declared the Biden
administration's use of a federal
workplace safety agency to impose a
vaccine and test mandate on private
employers to be unconstitutional but
even countries with relatively strong
institutions can lose those protections
quickly if they aren't Vigilant it
happened in Hong Kong starting in 2014
with the ascendancy of Xi Jinping to
power in China which culminated in the
near complete takeover of the local Hong
Kong government and jailing of
dissidents following the 2019
pro-democracy protests at the moment I
have to say that I'm pretty pessimistic
because it's just so difficult
to stop China
from extending the kind of power and
control that they wish for now that
President Biden has officially ended the
National Emergency in a terse one
sentence statement what can be done to
stop and reverse this trend there's a
story that Benjamin Franklin when asked
about the ideal form of government
replied a republic if you can keep it
the same might be said of the ideal
social Arrangement freedom
if you can keep it the bad news is that
the federal government is bigger than
ever and it's spending America ever
further into debt with less and less to
show for it trust and confidence in our
institutions continues its decline when
there is a loss of trust in the main
institutions in society that mediate
interaction in society you're in Latin
American territory and that's when Trump
came in I very much viewed Trump as a
Latin American populist he didn't come
out of nowhere something was going on in
the United States that led people to
think hey you know the rules of the game
aren't aren't Fair anymore we don't
trust this institution or that
institution but the sudden loss of
Liberty that the government response to
the pandemic brought may have awakened a
new appreciation for what freedoms we do
have and a newfound desire to expand
them protests and Disobedience made many
pandemic restrictions untenable the most
restrictive and dysfunctional cities and
states lost population many people woke
up to the Cozy censorious relationship
between big Tech and the government
parents fought District officials and
unions to reopen schools expand school
choice and undo scientific mandates we
believe a parent has the ultimate
Authority the ultimate right to the
fundamental right to guide and direct
the upbringing the medical care and the
education of their children the world
was once trending towards freedom
maybe it can again
what vasquez's work also shows is that
the struggle is worth it it does appeal
to a lot of people to be the author of
their own lives so there's an inherent
value but beyond that we also know that
freedom plays a central role in human
progress we can see the strong
relationship between freedom and
prosperity and indicators of human
well-being across the board that is a
huge Triumph of Classical liberalism
what is literally happening is that the
free countries are lifting up all of
humanity because in the poorest
countries you see people using cell
phones taking medicines that are
invented in in free countries benefiting
from Capital that comes in from free
countries the freedom of the free
benefits not only the free it benefits
everybody hey thanks for watching if
you'd like to see our full unedited
conversation with Ian Vasquez about the
state of human freedom in the U.S and
worldwide click here for an excerpt from
that conversation click here
[Music]